la Unión Europea recibe su primer gran
choque diplomático con Israel desde la
Asunción del gobierno de extrema derecha
liderado por Benjamín netañahu en una
decisión sin precedentes en la
delegación europea en Israel canceló su
tradicional recepción en tel aviv por el
día de Europa para impedir la
participación del ministro de seguridad
y tomar benhibir líder del partido
supremacista y anti árabe poder judío
esta acción tan directa sorprende porque
Bruselas no suele enfrentarse con el
estado hebreo sin embargo en una reunión
extraordinaria Los embajadores europeos
tomaron esta medida con las únicas
oposiciones de Hungría y Polonia la
representación europea alega que la
cancelación Busca evitar dar una
plataforma a alguien cuyas miradas se
contradicen los valores que defiende la
Unión Europea decisión que venga y vivir
calificó Poco después de amordazamiento
poco diplomático pese a los reparos
europeos en la oficina de benjivir había
confirmado el domingo que le estaba
decidido a participar del acto y que
tenía previsto cuestionar el uso
inapropiado de los fondos europeos en y
una parte del dinero destinado a apoyar
a los palestinos precisamente esta
cancelación ocurre 24 horas después de
que las fuerzas israelíes le molieran
una escuela en el área de Belén en
sijordania ocupada que había sido
financiada por la Unión Europea y donde
estudiaban 60 niños palestinos una
medida que como es habitual también fue
condenada por la delegación europea para
los territorios palestinos todo esto
además se da en medio de un
enfrentamiento en 30 días y benjivire
quien está boicoteando sesiones
parlamentarias y amenazas con romper la
coalición si el gobierno no adopta una
línea aún más dura contra los palestinos
en sí Jordania y si no reactiva la
controvertida reforma judicial que ha
causado ya 18 semanas de protestas y
sobre la cual también ha manifestado su
preocupación la Unión Europea